i don't really care about what they say
you know this is my second year in the
league many people don't be able to make
it to the playoffs i got a great team
with me we didn't really worry about
what the people saying we're just going
to keep going like i said get ready for
nation i know how he's going to respond
you know he's going to he's going to
respond by being extremely motivated and
determined to improve as a football
player and i think the strides you made
between last year and this year
are pretty indicative of that and we
expect them to continue to get better
lamar jackson first then john harbaugh
after that ravens quarterback and head
coach following a disappointing ending
to a special season felt like a team of
destiny at 14-2 captured the imagination
of sports fans across the country and
beyond and couldn't get it done at home
out
in the first playoff game they played
for the second straight season where do
the baltimore ravens go from here as
they try not only to replicate what they
did in the regular season peter but also
to be ready to win when they get to
january of 2021.
yeah and mike i think the baltimore
ravens now
one of the one of the things i like
about the ravens okay this was true
under ozzie newsome might even be more
true under eric decosta who i think has
has sort of added more of an emphasis of
of analytics and
just imagination eric decosta is an
outside the box thinker and i think this
coming off season i'm really really
interested to see
what the ravens do
okay because they're definitely not a
finished product
um they might be facing the retirement
of a potential hall of fame guard in
martial yonda he seemed a little
sentimental after the game
uh it brought his family down to the
field and took some photos after that
game so you never know with that one but
he's been playing and paying the last
couple of years it would not surprise me
um and in addition to that in addition
to that they need to make a decision on
a couple of very important players
number one is jimmy smith who i think
has had an in and out ravens career but
more in than out he's a valuable piece
of a stocked secondary and then the
other one i think is the long-term
future of marlon humphrey just as i say
the ravens have a secondary to be proud
of but they want to be able to keep that
secondary so
i think those are kind of the decisions
you look forward to in the offseason i
will guarantee you there will be a
surprise in the baltimore ravens
offseason i don't have any idea what it
is but this is a team that prides itself
on doing things a little bit differently
and that has resulted in a winning
formula with the ravens
well and now that they have a team that
is regarded as special a quarterback
that other players are in awe of peter
that could prompt free agents to want to
come to baltimore and take less to go to
the ravens than they would want
somewhere else remember last year they
couldn't get any free agent receivers to
join the team because of the perception
it was going to be a complete and total
run-based offense well the ball is being
thrown maybe not as much as it is
elsewhere but there could be some guys
out there whether it's receiver or
defensive players offensive linemen
there there could be plenty of guys who
say i want to be part of this i want
lamar jackson as my teammate for the
next three four five years
i found myself watching the nfl
late in this season and every time you
would see brashad perryman make a circus
catch from jameis winston i would say
could you imagine if the ravens had
rashad perryman still
you know that would be one area of the
team where they wouldn't even have to
remotely think of stocking up because
they would be fine you know with
hollywood brown and rashad perryman as
two first-round picks that were going to
buttress that
position group for years to come but of
course perryman could never stay healthy
you can't blame the ravens uh for for
you know not not keeping them because he
couldn't stay on the field but
i'll tell you what he's a special
receiver when he's on the field
yeah i agree with you and there may be
some special receivers that want to be
on the field with lamar jackson now
lamar jackson not being on the field
week 17.
there hasn't been a whole lot of talk
about this and jim or john harbaugh
excuse me did the best he could to
tiptoe around it when it came up after
the loss not playing the key starters
week 17
having that 20-day gap between the last
game they played in and their
postseason opener you know it's another
data point peter for the next time the
question comes up of what a team that
has locked up a buy and has nothing else
to play for should do in week 17 and
this data point favors playing your guys
no question about it mike and i think if
you asked tony dungy and mike mccarthy
two guys who famously over the years
had that rest this actually was a 19-day
break between games because the ravens
played on saturday but still in all
you know you have to ask yourself is it
smart
to have inactivity for
in the ravens case okay you can't really
include mark andrews or mark ingram
because they were injured or really
banged up and they would have been held
out anyway there were five key guys
including lamar jackson who didn't play
in week 17. lamar jackson and ronnie
stanley i think if you're going to bench
ronnie stanley you're probably not going
to play lamar jackson either you know
because you don't want him playing
behind a neil fight left side of your
line but i think the thing i would say
mike i wrote this in my column yesterday
you know we've talked a little bit you
know in this show today about how much
the ravens love analytics and accept the
analytics
john harbaugh said after this game it's
unanswerable
whether uh you know it would have made a
difference to play some of their guys in
a meaningless week 17 game
it might be unanswerable but i'm not so
sure
why can't you take your analytics people
and look at every time since 1990
where your team has rested people in
week 17 and then had a buy okay and and
how have they played what happened let's
at least see the data
you know if it's more common
that the the number that the that the
seeds that get the bye week if it's more
common that they either perform poorly
or they lose maybe you'd want to keep
that in mind if you have to make that
same decision in 2020.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports